yeah it's it's been a long time since
I've been back to the world welcome to
Hollywood the home of secrets and lies
we are coming to you from the shrine the
only theater in America not showing why
the Star Wars movies but it's great to
be back here at the show or as it's
known this year's Sundance by the sea
things are a little different this year
it's a little different into last time I
was here back then there was war in
Bosnia and peace in the rap music
industry back then I thought Bruno Mali
was a star Ville Postino and back then
and awareness one of all the major
studios were nominated for Oscars it was
a strange time this year as you know
only one out of 163 major at least Jerry
Maguire is nominated for Best Picture
one out of a hundred and sixty-three
major releases one hundred sixty four if
you count Michael Ovitz and so that's a
different thing
I love this band
it's the year of the independent film
great performances new faces among the
nominees I mean really new faces who are
you people
I'll tell you who they are they're
unbelievably talented people some of
them how to show photo ID to get in
there tonight and few of them are
actually carpooled it's a little
difference in budgets but great films
unusual films risky's plots great
Direction great scripts like Fargo
amazing funny movie with a lot of blood
and guts directed by the Coen brothers
right
the Coen Brothers Erik and Lyle it's a
rather violent movie and
a lot of great performances look at Best
Actor I love this category they're all
damaged guys you got a burnt guy
mentally challenged guy mentally abused
guy paralyzed guy agent and four out of
the five are treatable that's what this
is
but I'm great memorable characters this
year I'm just gonna stare at you for a
while great and that with his yin to the
yang was Geoffrey Rush's to do a sequel
these two guys is detectives that'll be
the major studio thing well maybe we
should go into the bad guys they are the
bad guys all not good guys good bad guys
with the bad guys or anything I'm just
gonna kill you but in Hollywood I was a
huge year big here special effects
movies actors have to do things with
computers and you know that the scene is
going to be there months later like
twister they simulate 200 mile an hour
winds 200 miles an hour that's almost
enough wind to blow Gloria Steinem into
a screening of Larry Flynt you realize
how
almost apparently there was a little bit
of breeze today because Larry's here
with us nice to see Larry glad you're
here
special effects are amazing I have to
tell you something since I last seen you
a couple of years now I have been
digitally enhanced myself you see right
after I was born there was what you
would call a rough edit made at a
religious ceremony so I had them restore
the missing footage hey I was a kid the
rabbi had final cut what do you want for
me
but tonight nobody knows who's going to
go home with the Oscar the only one
guaranteed of waking up with a statue is
Tipper Gore so
you're a good crowd
don't turn sounded like a disney
stockholders meeting there just for a
little while in the last few weeks
everyone has been really kind to me as
the show approached and everyone has
been coming up to me saying hey bill you
can sing one of them best picture
medleys like you always do and the
answer is yeah nice for
by pictures nominated for Best Picture
our is the story of a British lady with
a most ungrateful daughter on this earth
now this lady also had a brother whose
wife could not give birth it's the story
of a secret daughter
who she gave him her adoption through
her crisis laws yes his mother's never
seen his daughter she's in for some
surprise and so one day that his father
met this daughter and she knew that it
was much more than a tan
so she had to make the big confession
you should know that Dennis Rodman's
your old man live tattoos on thighs it's
so hard keeping those secrets and lies
all he's got is a room somewhere and
long long flashbacks of his affair but
no skin no is no hair he's great
the English Patient he's in pain and
he's out of luck
he's as crispy as Peking Duck he cheats
he spies fresh luck no he's right
the English Patient
let's give the chair to Jerry Maguire a
very rare agent he's not a liar he's the
studio's only hope
and Athena when it break out the rope
everyone loves him Tom you could win
everyone seen it even in Berlin and if
you
score this bowl you still go home with
Nicole
listen too much sorry it's a crazy
little scene about a piano playing kid
who had a father who is mainly made him
practice the piano to his fingers almost
bled it when the cable off the college
that he said my son is dead
very meta teacher was big on the rock
trees a little baby tried to play and he
played it beautifully but as he hit the
final note a little here at the florid
seems he went a little nuts in heaven
knows his head was sore so we stayed in
the towel until he told him he could go
we had too much electric shock he waited
night by using blow and though he's got
a little funny well he got himself a gig
and then he met a little lady with a
heart to join babe so we get a happy
ending with a concert and wife we wanted
anyone can copy all the absolutes of
life Oscar may send a Valentine to a
sports fan woof let's go shine
this is our
and Frank this is my kind of town that
Fargo is my kind of pound that Fargo is
my kind
people who shoot at you
each time I leave that blood and snow
whoo Sam I got to keep in old Fargo
lactating Sheriff I Pardo in Rome and
stuffed in wood chippers my Fargo is a
place so bloody you could drown it's a
Cole Brothers kind of
the night they'll live that fantasy bill
by font in the Oscars it
say hi to Edward Norton biasted Lauren
Bacall it's your first time it's here
all of your here for Oscars 69
and
we the Oscars